hello everyone my name is Lily and I'm
here to announce a brand new series on
every channel called unlocking Lily so I
had my first sit-down with Evan about a
year and a half ago as an instructor at
his dance studio during the meeting he
told me that he really liked me and he
wanted to start some sort of business
with me so my first thought was wow he
is so nice and what an amazing
confidence booster for me then my second
thought was I don't have a business plan
oh my gosh I don't even have a business
idea I've never thought about becoming
an entrepreneur I don't think that's
something I'm supposed to do with my
life so that's where it kind of ended I
went on to continue to teach at in dance
studio
but the thought always remains in the
back of my mind so it was fine you know
things things progressed on I continued
to teach out of stand school as I got to
know him better and we had more sit-down
I decided that maybe I'll let him know
about my dreams my dream is to go on
stage one day and be a seeker
I have no idea how I don't know when I
don't know what I'm gonna say I have no
experience but I knew this is something
I wanted to do with my life but I just
didn't know how to get it
so last week he decided to do something
rather crazy
he offered me $50,000 to quit my
full-time job that I've been at for 12
years to pursue my dream of public
speaking full-time as he was mentioning
this to me I already made up my mind he
doesn't know that I already knew that I
would say yes but of course I didn't
want to verbally commit knowing that
there's so many things die that could go
wrong ever since I became an adult at 21
and 20 I always been financially secure
that's something that was very important
to me growing up for me to take this
leap of faith it means that I may not be
financially secure I may not be able to
provide a life for me and my husband
that I've always promised that I will
and that was my biggest concern I needed
to talk to my husband before I actually
said anything to him but even though I
knew this is something that I wanted to
do that is the only thing I have
perfectly wanted to do in my life
more than anything else so I thought to
my husband and he was so incredibly
supportive and he knew that I needed to
do this it's it's really now or never if
I didn't do this now I will live and die
never pursuing my dream so I accepted
his offer at midnight Hey
I sent him a message and the next day I
told my boss that I'll be leaving my job
that I have been with a company for 12
years
and it was really really hard for me
because I have been so happy at my job I
love the people there I love my boss -
she's wonderful for me to say that I'm
going to be leaving the secure wonderful
job that I've been at for 12 years with
all the friends I created to tell them
that I'm going to be doing this because
I'm going to be suing my dream of public
speaking
it was crazy crazy for me
[Applause]
you see we don't have a plan the plan is
to make a plan I'm taking a giant leap
of faith with Evan and stepping into the
unknown but I know it's going to work
out and we're going to bring you on this
journey that one's called unlocking
Lilly as I learn grow make mistakes have
wins you get to come with me you're
going to even sit in on my mentoring
meetings with Evan my practice sessions
my confessional thoughts and watch me
conquer my dream and I hope I see me go
for it it inspires you as well and at
the very least cheer me on because I'm
going to need your support I'm going to
need a shoulder to cry on when things
are tough I'm going to need to celebrate
with you
when I have my victories this is going
to be a weekly series on Evans channel
where I'm going to film and I hope you
tune in and if you have any questions
suggestions please leave in the comments
I promise you I'm paying attention and I
will take everything to heart so stay
tuned for unlocking Lilly episode one
thank you so much relief nation I am so
incredibly excited and grateful and
honored and I hope to see you very soon